[موسيقى]
ليست المره الاولى التي تمتد فيها ايدي
الحقد والجهل والتخلف لتسيء الى كلام الله
ولا يبدو انها ستكون الاخيره لكن القران
الكريم محفوظ ليس بضمانه جامعه الدول
العربيه مستمعه او متفرقه وليس بعهده
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي غير المتعاونه
انما القران محفوظ بالقران وببشر الايه
التاسعه من سوره الحجر انا نحن نزلنا
الذكر وانا له لحافظون صدق الله العظيم
لكن يسال احد المشايخ الزهاد هل يغري بعض
قاده العالم الاسلامي قبل ان يرحل عن هذه
الدنيا ايلقوا ربهم وقد دافعوا عن قرانه
عسى ان يغفر لهم ذنوب بطشهم
ولشعوبهم ذنوب الصمت والهوان فالناس على
دين ملوكههم يرقصون على
عيد وفوفهم
ليس المطلوب اعلان حرب وتجهيز جيوش يضيف
الشيخ فلسنا في زمن الصديق والفاروق
والكرار وذي النورين كل المطلوب ضغط حقيقي
على المجتمع الدولي لاستصدار قانون عالمي
يمنع ازدراء الاديان كل الاديان فيخرس
المستهزئون ويهدا الغاضبون وحتى ذلك الحين
نردد مع الامام الشافعي اعرض عن الجاهل
السفيه فكل ما قال فهو فيه ما ضر بحر
الفرات يوما ان خاض بعض الكلاب فيه الى
العناوين
احراق المصحف الشريف
بترخيص من حكومه السويد
اردوغان يعاقب السويد بمنع انضمامها الى
حلف الناتو
كاهن مسيحي لبناني في مناهج السويد
التربويه لا وجود لله وللعائله
فيلسوف فرنسي ينعي اوروبا الغربيه غير اسف
على حضارتها
وزير البصل يغادر حكومه نتنياهو قبل
دخولها بتهم فساد
رئيسه هيئه السعاده في مصر حاولت الانتحار
اكثر من مره
نائبه بحرينيه تقترح بناء فندق في المقبره
لجلب السياح
[موسيقى]
مرحبا يواصل الجيش الروسي ما يصفه مراقبون
بدمج السياسه والجيش بالدين وهذا لا يقتصر
على المسيحيين بل يشمل ايضا المسلمين في
القوات الشيشانيه المقاتله في اوكرانيا
على وقع التكبيره في عيد الغطاس
الارثوذكسي اقامه قساوسه الكنيسه في قاعده
حميميم الجويه الروسيه بسوريا طقوسا دينيه
لمقاتل الجيش النظامي الروسي الذي تقاتل
الى جانبه المرتزقه
هذا المشهد يصنف علميا على انه فعله
مباركه من الكنيسه بما تحمله وتمثله من
عقيده دينيه لاعمال العنف والحرب التي
يشدها جيش بلادها خارج بلادها في الغرب لم
يبقى ديك تقريبا الا واتهم روسيا بارتكاب
جرائم حرب لكن صوصا لم يفكر ولحسن الحظ
طبعا باحراق الكتاب المقدس التي تسير
الكنيسه على تعاليمه
بتلخيصا رسميا من سلطات السويد وبحمايه
وبواكبه من شرطتها يعيد اليمني المتطرف
المشبوه رسمه بلودان احراق نسخه من المصحف
الشريف
والتطابل على الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام
واتهام الاسلامي بالارهاب امام مقر
السفاره التركيه في ستوكهولم على مرء من
الكاميرات التي دعيت لتصوير الجريمه في
مشهد يختلط فيه الجهل بالاسلام والحقد
عليه بحلق السويد على تركيا التي تفرض
كلمه سر تفتح ستوكهولم بوابه انضمامها
لحلف الناتو هذه الكلمه هي محاربه ارهاب
مجموعات كرديه ترعاها السويد بحسب توصيف
انقره
بحرق نسخه من القران قابله في اسطنبول
اضرام النار بالعالم السويدي امام قنصليه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان سارع الى
الاعلان عن معاقبه السويد بمحاربه
انضمامها للناتو واصفا جريمهي حرق المصحف
والترخيص للحرق بالعمل الخائن الوغد
الدنيء بوليسي
تحت حمايه الامن والشرطه وتباهما فعل ذلك
لاستهدافه للمسلمين لذا فانه من الواضح
انه لن ينتظر من سمح لهذا الفعل المخزي ان
يحدث امام سفارتنا ان نقدم له الدعمه
بخصوص موضوع طلبهم لعضويه نيته لا داعي
للاداره في السويد ان تحدثنا عن الحقوق
والحريات اذا كنتم تحترمون الحقوق
والحريات في هذه الدرجه فعليكم اولا ان
تحترموا المعتقد الدينيه للجمهوريه
التركيه وللمسلمين اولا ومن وزير الدفاع
التركي خلصي اقار برقيه عاجله عبر الاع
زياره وزير الدفاع السويدي بال جونسون
بلاها وبلا بلاها فالزيارته فقدت معناها
والضيف الثقيل الذي كان مقررا اي يزور
انقره غير مرحب به في هذه المرحله فقدت
زياره وزير الدفاع السويدي جونسون لتركيا
في السابع والعشرين من يناير اهميتها
ومعناها لذلك الغناء اشار وزير الخارجيه
السويديسترو ستر قالوا في لغه الشارع
الشاميه يؤكد توبياس هذا ان الاستفزازات
المعاديه للاسلام مروعه لكن السويد لديها
حريه تعبير كبيره كيف يعني طيب المؤسسات
والاعلاميه هي منارات وحريه التعبير
المفترضه فهل يحق لي مثلا ان امزق علم
السويد على الهواء واحرقه واحتقيقه
تبيحه كل حروماتكم بدعوى الحريه ثم تقول
شبكه الجزيره بعدها ان هذا العمل الذي
اقدم عليه نزيه مرووع لكننا نظمنه ونحترم
حريه الترويع والتشنيع الملقبه عندكم
بحريه التعبير والتفكير جرائم الكراهيه
والعنصريه ليست حريه التعبير كما انها
ليست وفقا للقانون السويدي ايضا الاخبار
التي تفيد به احراق النسخه من القران
الكريم يعمل [__] اموله ان تتخذ السلطات
السويديه واجراءا لمنع حرق المصحف لا
يسمحون باحراق الكتب الاخرى لكن عندما
يتعلق الامر بالقران الكريم
تركيا هم ردوا على حرق بلودان البلدين
نسخه من المصحف الشريف بجوله على هذه
الكنائس وتوزيع الورود على كهنتها فلا تزر
وازره وزر اخرى علمهم القران الكريم
الساحقه من انظمه الحكم في الغرب لا تتبنى
المسيحيه فالاساءات المتواصله للاسلام
ليست مشكله بين المسيحيين والمسلمين بل هي
عدوان مقانا ومنظم من استبداد علمانيه ولا
ديني مورس على المسيحيه قبل الاسلام يقول
بعض النقاب مناهجهم التربويه وخصوصا في
السويد تلغي الدين وتلغي العائله وتبيح كل
المحرمات وتفضي الى عمليات انتحار يوميا
للاطفال والشباب بحسب القسيس اللبناني
الاب راي عبدالله حزينه
وعيش بالسويد سالت لها المراه شو الحياه
اللي عايشين بره
قالت لي ابونا ما في حياه ممنوع تعلم
اولادك على الصلاه
هذا اللي ببكي انه نحن مفكرين حياتنا
متخلفين لانه بعد عنا مبادئ وحب للعائله
قلت لي ما فينا نقول لهم شيء لاولادنا
وبيوصلوا لمرحله ما فيك تعيط عليها ما فيك
تحكي ما فيك تقول له ما فيك تعلمه عن الله
بتمسخروا عليه بالمدرسه اذا قال انه بحب
يسوع لانه ما في الله بقى بالكتب قالت لي
كل جمعه في امتحانات او ثلاثه بالمدارس
والجامعات دوله المجر رئيس الوزراء بياخذ
قرار بيطلع قانون انه ممنوع الاولاد بعمر
صغير يتعلموا مثلا عن المثليه الجنسيه
عملوا عقوبات على البلد من الاتحاد
الاوروبي لانه يخالف نظام الاتحاد
الاوروبي كما يقول الاب عبد الله فان
القوانين السويديه تمجد المثليه
اختطاف الاطفال وتحديدا اطفال المسلمين من
حضن ذويهم بحجه حمايتهم اجتماعيا ولبس
عندهم ايود على الاطفال ازواجا مثليين كما
حدث مع عده اطفال مسلمين بينهم مريم
التركيه وعبد الله المقدوني وفي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحقيق صحفي يتهم مثليين
باغتصاب طفلين تبنياهما واجبارهما على
البغاء لجمع المال
التحقيق والاستقصائي امتد لاشهر واجرته
الصحفيه كاسل لصالح شبكه تاون هول وكشف
توزيع المثليين موده اباحيه للاطفال تحتوي
مشاهد اعتداء جنسيه علما ان المثليين قد
تبنياه طفلين من وكاله التبني المسيحيه
لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه بحسب الصحيفه بهيج
اللي بقلبه على لسانه سال احد القضاه هل
تستطيع محاكم الدول العربيه والاسلاميه
اصدار مذكرات قبضا على هذا البالون
بالودان فرد القاضي بان بعض المحاكم
العربيه تستجوب المشايخ حول صلاتهم على
الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام في بدايه
احاديثهم اتريد من هؤلاء ما تريد
دائما
في الصلاه على
بحب النبي
[موسيقى]
يكون سائقه قطار فاذا به من ابرز مفكرين
الجيل الجديد في فرنسا ومن وجوه اليسار
المعادي للبرادي المتوحشه كما توصف ميشال
اوفراي الفيلسوف الفرنسي المعاصر الاكثر
غزاره وظهور في الاعلام يدعي اوروبا على
ان تقبل التعازي في امريكا واستراليا فهذا
مصير الحضارات نشاه فشباب فهرم فموت وارحم
عزيزه قوم حاول
قلوب قلوب
جيشها على ارضها وبلغه فجاه
بوركينا فاسو برحيل الجنوبي الفرنسيه
الخلطه الاوراق بشان الشراكه بين فرنسا
ومستعمراتها السابقات في وقت تكثر
المؤشرات على تقارب عسكريا مع روسيا
لكافه تعهدات اعمال القتل والتدمير والتي
صنفتها الولايات المتحده هذا الاسبوع على
انها منظمه اجراميه دوليه اكراما للدم
الاوكراني وليس السوري تسعى لانشاء جبهه
من المرتزقه الصلب للقتال في اوكرانيا
تواجه جدلا واسعا نشرت هذه المجموعه
الروسيه اعلانا محليا يدعو الصلب الى
القتال في اوكرانيا لتقدم جامعات مناهضه
للحرب شكاوى ضد سفير الروسي
لنتذكر معا قصه زعيم حزب شات الاسرائيلي
المتطرف الحاخام اريي درعي مع البصل عندما
وضعه على عينيه ليمثل دور الباك المحزون
امام مريديه لاظهار اسفل مصطنع على موت
ايقونه الارهاب الزعيم الرحيل للحزب عفاد
يا يوسف
للبصل فوائد صحيه كبيره ونظرا لعلاقه درع
بالبصل عينه بنيامين نتنياهو وزيرا للصحه
في حكومه الحخامات كما توصف لكن تهمى
الفساد الموثقه بحق الحخام درعي ابطلت
وزارته بقرار قضائي تلقاه نتنياهو بكثير
من الحزن والاسى على خسارته هذا الفاسد
الاصيل وتعهد نتنياهو باعادته قريبا الى
الحكومه مقعد يتيم حول طاوله الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
بعد قرار رئيس الوزراء بنيمنتنياهو اقاله
وزير الداخليه والصحه لدير امتتالا لقرار
المحكمه العليا التي قضت الاسبوع الماضي
بعدم دستوريه درع بسبب تهم الفساد الموجات
اليه
مشاهد صادمه صورتها كاميرا في فنزويلا
لتخلص احد المواطنين من كميات كبيره من
عمله بلاده في حاويه القمامه بعدما اقترب
الدولار الواحد من مليونين بوليفار
فنزويلي مشهد يخيف اللبنانيين الان قبل
غيرهم مع تجاوز الدولار الامريكي عاتبت
الخمسين الف ليره لبنانيه
كثيرون يعتقدون ان الجنيه المصري ليس بخير
هو بخير بل ان الدولار الامريكي مهدد
بالانهيار امام الجنيه بحسب خبير البورصه
احمد موسى البنك المركزي الروسي اعتبارا
من اليوم من اليوم التعامل بالجنيه المصري
وده بالمناسبه هيكون ضربه كبيره ايضا
للدولار واللي معه دولار يخلي باله من
الدولار اللي عنده الدولار رايح فين خبر
قراه ابراهيم عيسى ربما بفرح داخلي لانه
كما تعلمون يقدس البقره والخبر يتحدث عن
تراجع اكل اللحوم في مصر بنسبه
85% انه مركز ابحاث الغذاء العالمي مطلع
تقرير من مارس 22 الى الان المصريين خلال
الشهور الاخيره
حصل تراجع في استهلاك اللحمه
85% في هذه الظروف الصعبه لا بد من بث
الطاقه الايجابيه بين الناس فتم انشائه
اداره حكوميه جديده تحت اسم فن اداره
الحياه
بس الطاقه الايجابيه ومساعده الناس على
تخطي الازمات الحياتيه واختيار طبعا
الطريقه الصحيحه عشان يحققوا نجاحات
الاداره دي هتكون تابعه لوزاره الشباب
والرياضه وهتتولى رئاستها الدكتوره نرفانا
خالصه مؤسسه الطاقه الايجابيه والسعاده
حاولت تنتحر ثلاث مرات لكنها فشلت كما
فشلت في مهنه المحاماه وفي زواجها هي صرحت
بذلك لسكاي نيوز فهل تنجح في اسعاد
المصريين دكتوره ايفانا فاضل كانت بتحكي
عن ازاي عمله الهيئه دي وازاي هي بقت
راسها فبتقول كنت اعمل محاميه في الشؤون
القانونيه بوزاره الشباب والرياضه ولكنني
لم اكن احب هذا العمل وكنت اشعر باحضاض
شديد وحاولت الانتحار اكثر من مره خاصه
انني انفصلت عن زوجي نقطه التحول التاريخي
في حياته رئيسه السعاده نيفين كانت فيلم
اجنبيا شاهدته فتغيرت نظرتها للحياه تقول
وتولدت لديها طاقه كبيره تريد ان توزعها
على الاخر اختي الكريمه اذا بدل ان تفتح
مؤسسه السعاده افتحي سينما سينما السعاده
بدوام كامل وعنده فيها هالافلام الي عم
تحضريها بعدما شاهدت فيلم الاجنبيا نظراتي
للحياه واتولدت لدي طاقه كبيره ورغبه مني
في تطويع تلك الطاقه لخدمه الناس الازمه
المعيشيه ضربت الفقراء في مصر لكنها في
سوريا تضرب الرئيس النائب السوري الظاهره
خالد العبود يحدث ضجه عند الموالينا
للنظام قبل المعارضين يقول خالد ان بشار
الاسد موظف عادي وان راتبه لا يكفيه بضعه
ايام لمصروف اسرته خالد العبود يقول فيها
ان بشار مثله مثل اي موظف عادي وراتبه لا
يكفيه سوى بضعه ايام وذهب ناشطون لاكمال
روايه العبود للحديث عن عمل بشار سائقا
وشبير تاكسي على طريق المهاجرين مزج جبل
[موسيقى]
ايام السجن معروضه للبيع في اقتراح لوزير
العدل المغربي عبد اللطيف وهبي بهدف تخفيف
اقتضاض السجون وهكذا تصبح السجون مكانا
حصريا للفقراء
اقل من سنتين يمكن مقابل ان يدخل السجن
الدوله
ولا يدخل السجن نبقى في اخبار السجون
ونتحول الى العراقيه منها حيث يوجد العديد
من مدمدي المخدرات الذين لم يكونوا كذلك
قبل السجن بل ادمدوها في الداخل او اجبر
على ادمانها لان السجان يريد بيعهم
المخدرات وتحقيق الارباح وهكذا يتحولون
الى مدمنين وعندما تنتهي محكمياتهم يقبض
عليهم مره اخرى بتهمه تعاطي المخدرات
فيرجعون الى سوق التداول الى قرر وزير
العدل خالد جواني اعفاء مدير سجن التاجي
ومعاويه من مناصبهم واحالهم على الجهات
التحقيقيه بشان ما ورد من اتهامات في
الفيديو المسرب من داخل السجن وكان مقطع
فيديو قد اظهر سجناء يزعمون انهم نزلاء في
السجن التاجي شمال العاصمه بغداد يستغيثون
فيه من تعرضهم لضغوط من قبل مدير السجن
وبعض المسؤولين فيه لاجبارهم على تعاطي
المخدرات كما انه يتم بيع جهاز الموبايل
للسجناء مقابل سعر مليون ونصف المليون
دينار وفي العراق
افاصل وطاء في محاسبه ناشري المحتوى
الرديء في مواقع التواصل العراقيه ومن
البحرين فكره اكثر ابداعا تطرحها نائبه
صاعده لماذا لا نحول المقبره القديمه الى
فندق خمس نجوم او خمسه قبور بدل فيرمونت
فيرمونت ما شفت من ابلاكما في احلى مثلا
انك تفوت على غرفه النوم تلاقي اكفان بدل
المناشف وهل يوجد اجمل من مشهد المقابر
عند الصباح لما بتفتح الشباك لجلب السياح
مقابر علي مساحتها كبيره ناخذ جزء منها
نبنيها فندق
نعزز من الحركه السياحيه في ريع في تجاره
لا بد من قطار صغير يستحسن ان يكون على
شكل سياره دفن الموتى ينقل السائح من
مقبره الى اخرى
زميلته بفندق
يستشهد ببيت شعري فيتحولوا معه ابو العلاء
المعري الى ابو العلى ويعريه او يجعله
معريا لغيره فيصبح ابو العلا المعري يرتفع
به عدد اعضاء لجنه تحكيم برنامج امير
الشعراء الثلاثه التي اضيف اليها الاسبوع
الماضي حكم الظفره الى خمسه
صاحي هذه قبورنا تملا تملا الرحبه فاين
القبور من عهد عاد
[موسيقى]
ختاما القران الكريم الذي يسيء اليه بعض
من لم يتعرف عليه يامر ببر الوالدين وباي
يكبيرا عمرا ويكبرا قدرا في كنف ابنائهم
وليس في ماوى العجزه فالاه لا يدعون
اطفالهم والاطفال من صحن الكعبه المشرفه
يتكرر المشهد الجليل مع ابناء بارين
بابائهم وامهاتهم يحملونهم على ظهورهم
طوافا وربما يكون طوافا الوداع من سوره
الاسراء
وقضى ربك الا تعبدوا الا اياه وبالوالدين
احسانا اما يبلغن عندك الكبر احدهما او
كلاهما فلا تقل لهما اف ولا تنهرهما وقل
لهما قولا كريما صدق الله العظيم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]